[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing the infamous
killing curse avada kadavra more
specifically i'm going to be discussing
the use of the fatal curse
why it's unforgivable and how it could
actually possibly be
merciful why is zafada kadavra banned
specifically when there are plenty of
other ways to end someone's life
why is zavada kadavra so bad when you
can just bombard a maxima someone
let's dive into it further first things
first what
is avada kadavra avada kadavra is one of
three curses
classified as unforgivable dark and
powerful spells
dubbed so morally questionable that they
were banned in the wizarding world
the unforgivable curses are tools of the
dark arts and generally only used by the
darkest and most sadistic witches and
wizards
these unforgivable curses are comprised
of crucio
imperio and avada cadavra the effects of
the spells vary
crucio aka the cruciatus curse is
designed to cause torturous pain
imperio aka the imperius curse is almost
like a form of mind control
and forces the victim to perform the
unquestioned bidding of the caster
avada kadavra on the other hand is much
more simple it just
kills people if you want to kill someone
and you're not afraid of breaking
wizarding law
then this is the spell to use when cast
it creates a blindingly intense green
wall of light
right before the victim simply drops
dead all three curses require proper
intent
and proficient ability at performing
magic in order to cast
otherwise they are relatively
ineffective but what you may ask is the
reason for the unforgivable status of
avada kedavra
crucio torches and it tortures more than
any other spell
so i get that one imperio is basically
mind control
and no other spell does that so again
the unforgivable
label is warranted but killing there are
plenty of spells that bear the capacity
to kill bombarded maxima fiendfire
sectim's emperor
confringo all these bear the capacity to
kill a target
and more what makes avada kadavra
different
first of all there's no confirmed
explanation as for how avada kadavra
actually kills you
from the outside perspective by the time
the blindingly intense flash of green
light is produced
the victim is dead what i can say is
this
they die instantaneously and in the
muggle world instantaneous death
achieved by lethal injection is often
considered humane
in the right context like when an
injured animal has no chance of survival
it ends a life with seemingly the least
suffering possible
bombarded maxima on the other hand can't
be a pleasant way to die
being blown to pieces so if it ends
their life instantly
without what appears to be any kind of
suffering why is it in fact
unforgivable first of all despite the
victims dying
seemingly instantly i think that's
actually a lot more happening than meets
the eye
in a video i made recently i had a few
theories for how avada kadavra actually
kills you
and one of the more convincing theories
that i landed on suggests that the soul
is magically ripped from the body
however there's more to it than that
because we know that dementors operate
in a similar fashion
but still leave you alive my theory is
that avada kadavra
similar to the way that dementor sucks
out the soul of a living being
takes their soul from them however the
difference between how evada cadaver
does it and how dementors do it
just boils down to the effectiveness at
which the soul is ripped from the body
dementors do it slowly draining them of
their life force
and leaving them with just enough
humanity to stay alive
avada kadavra on the other hand abruptly
rips the soul from the body
leaving them with nothing left so while
it may look unassuming at surface level
avada kedavra kills people in a way that
transcends their physical
form it's more sinister than just
blowing someone up
as it rocks their very soul additionally
it has been expressed that in order to
properly cast avada kadavra
true intent must be there so the very
fact that it's linked with such deep
and dark intent may be one of the
reasons that it's unforgivable
however if my theory is wrong and it
doesn't pertain to the soul
it just stops the organs instantly then
it may actually be one of the more
merciful ways to kill someone as it
simply ends their life
instantaneously without dragging out
their suffering
what do you guys think is avada kadavra
a sinister method of ripping out
someone's soul
or just a mislabeled weapon of mercy
until next time
you're a little scary sometimes you know
that brilliant but
scary who said that comment down below
you